you guys get trainings all the time and
trainings are really weak levers for
change
if you want to change what's going on
change the incentive structure you have
for your officers
and they started doing that and it turns
out
fewer black folks get beat up fewer
folks in general getting beat up fewer
black folks in particular fewer arrests
and i was like hey
fewer of these things would be good
maybe we can do this again
and that's how we started
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to yang speaks
the co-founder and ceo of the center for
policing equity
yale professor ted talker and now the
president
of justice rx philip ateeba goff
welcome phillip hey thanks for having me
phillip uh i'm so pumped to have you
because you are the smartest person i've
ever
met or heard of when it comes to uh
trying to actually solve for racism
particularly in the
environment of policing so who the heck
are you and how the heck did you come to
this work
[Laughter]
i am a man who collects apparently lots
of titles um
to be read on podcasts um
uh you know i'm a social scientist i'm a
nerd um
my the hashtag for the center for police
equity is the justice nerds yes we've
had that trademarked
um get the hoodies get the t-shirts um
and what that means is that i like to
figure out how to solve hard problems
some people like to run marathons i
don't understand that um
some people like to eat weird foods also
don't understand that i like that
you get the folks that like to solve
problems right like so okay so you're
weird that way you i'm two for
three weird foods and solving problems
i'm also with you in the
non-marathoning
so i just i like solving uh problems
that are difficult um
and i started doing that as someone who
was an academic my job was to
ask questions and find come up with
answers that people hadn't had uh
previously
and then i got tired of people just
writing that in journals for other five
other people to read
i was like these things i think work in
the world let's see because a doctor
that's got an idea about how your heart
works but can't
actually fix your heart is a crappy
doctor right
i'm a phd in social science i should be
able to figure out how it's working in
the world
and it turns out at the end of the day a
lot of the most powerful things to
actually change the world are the
stories that we tell about who we are
and so that's why i'm telling stories
and that's how i showed up here
well your story is incredible so i i
don't know this what the heck was your
thesis on
you talking about my dissertation yeah
i'm just we're so imagining you
on your ascent it's like you know you're
a phd candidate
etc etc i don't know that the process of
the phd could be called an ascent
um is more like a floundering bird with
cut wings
but um the thing that i was really
interested in when i got to grad school
was ideology
right i was i was interested in why
people thought the way they did and how
that shape
shaped things and it turns out that none
of the studies i did on that worked even
a little bit
um and so my very wise very gentle uh
phd advisor claude steele was like
hey that's going to be super successful
but let's start a second track of
research
and in there he tried he challenged me
to think about identity
as the most powerful um uh lever for
affecting change and so there what we
were looking at was whether or not
prejudice
was going to be a big factor in in uh
causing discrimination
or if threats to white identity were
going to be a bigger factor
and it was threats to white identity a
thousand times out of a thousand it was
a super replicable finding where when
white people were worried about being
seen as racist
they physically distanced themselves
from the people who they thought were
gonna call them racist
and that physical distancing was a kind
of discrimination
that leads to all kinds of interpersonal
things like if someone's pushing
themselves away from you like
do i do i smell like do you not like me
what's going on and so we knew that
there were collateral
bad consequences from that but most of
the literature was saying oh it was
prejudice that was predicting that
no it was an identity process and that
was the dissertation that became one of
the first
major publications i had oh what the
heck year was that
i think they finally gave me credit for
it in like 2005.
um i finished it up in like 2003 and
then there's that gap period where i was
off trying to get a job but 2005 is when
they finally gave me the degree
okay so 16 years ago you wrote a
dissertation
and it says that identity threat is uh
is the thing that
that sets people off uh really
fundamentally and that if they're afraid
you're gonna call them racist or you do
call them racists then they physically
recoil
which i would say is something that most
people now understand
[Laughter]
to be true i'm gonna skip that phd
dissertation just
hit the fast forward button uh uh so one
of the things that
i am trying to come up with uh this
might amuse you
is that right now we throw the word
racist around
uh a little bit too liberally in my mind
or what
excessively i should say not liberally
but like just just someone will screw up
in it like that's racist
and it's like that there's like no term
for it that somehow
less freighted and so i i was joking to
my my lovely wife was to put up with me
um like we needed an expression that's
like
that's something like like this is what
i came up with it's dumb but whatever
you'll like it because it's dumb um like
that was
an excessive expression of tribalism or
something where it's like instead of
saying that's racist
you just say like that was an excessive
expression of tribalism
jordan doesn't eat or to something that
makes it seem really clinical
and that it's not like like you're a
capital r racist because as soon as you
call someone a capital racist they you
know they shut down
what do you think doctor yeah
so that's a fascinating project um or
outcome i should say
um and it's actually you're right
everybody kind of gets well if you call
somebody a racist then they're gonna do
some some banana stuff but there's
actually to me there's still insights
going back to the dissertation
that are lessons i wish we would learn
um because
quite right people get upset at the word
but when you don't use the word it turns
out they don't care at all
they're not motivated to change their
thing and so the the the deal
the secret of that is for many folks
the only thing that matters is do you
think i'm a good person or do you not
think i'm a good person if i'm a good
person cool we don't have to do anything
we have to fix any of the structural
problems we don't have to actually
you know the outcomes are perfectly fine
if you think i'm a bad person well then
screw you
you're the worst person and you're the
real racist and that actually leaves us
with no levers
for making the change for actually
improving the conditions
so i don't think you're entirely wrong
that right there has to be a middle
ground language
that people will care about it but not
that anyone would care about excessive
expression or tribalism business you
know just go off their back
i think that it is a sub-optimal
solution that you've come up with yeah
but i do think we should talk about a
little bit more specifically at what
level is the problem happening
right so if someone says something and
it's offensive that's an interpersonal
kind of thing right and so i don't need
you to be a bigot
you could just not have learned that
that's not a thing that we say anymore i
don't like
how you talk to me like that be like hey
i don't like how you say that why
well because it hurts me i don't like it
for me but also
it's tied to these other things that are
associated with
deep level racism and so you didn't do
anything that's
like you didn't genocide anybody and i
don't need you to react like that's
what i'm talking about your character
but when you do it and then another
person and then another person another
person it adds up
to doing this stuff that's really bad at
an institutional and at a structural
level
and so if you guide people back up and
say hey compared to the things that this
is associated with this is nothing
but also don't do it because it's
associated with these other things that
are not nothing
that's a language that's it's more
nuanced but it's the kind of thing i
want people to be able to get into
well this to me is a complaint that i
have philip
is that um the structures being
completely demented
and racist is the problem in my mind
like
you know goes back generations and the
rest of it um but we've just become
fixated
on controlling modes of expression
it's like like if you say this then
that's the problems like let's like try
and solve the the big problem
which i think they're you know obviously
like like legitimate
massive uh debts owed to people and you
know like uh
inequities that are baked in um
and i want to try and uproot those i
mean when i ran for president on
universal basic income i was like let's
just freaking give people money like
this is one way we could like let like
start making things
like better more equal um and
uh anyway so that that and in my mind
and this is something you and i may
disagree on and i
obviously would love it if people um
avoided expressions that other people
find uh offensive problematic hurtful
etc etc um but i i feel like for
whatever reason like we're almost being
duped
like we're being duped into paying
attention to whether someone
uh like says the right things while the
structures just keep on
grinding on um in terrible terrible ways
yeah it's that's a framing that i i hear
a lot and it makes sense from one
perspective
because if it's a bunch of well-to-do
folks in brooklyn
telling me how i should talk about
sexual identity
right or how i should talk about race
even more so i'm like
yeah i'm not really sure that that's the
thing i want to be spending my time on
but i don't think it has to be either or
so part of the reason why i think we're
seeing so much
policing of language is because the
folks
who haven't been in charge of that are
getting platforms to demand that there's
different language
like there was different language when
powerful people needed it
around how we think about anti-choice
movements right that became the
republicans are experts at terminology
they're just so much better at naming
[ __ ]
it's it's wild it's like we're just
gonna rename the estate tax the death
tax and everyone will hate it
we're gonna we're gonna call union
busting rules right to work laws every
you know
it's like up us down black is white
everything is is inverse and so the deal
is the folks who had a lot of money
spent a lot of money saying you don't
say this you say this other thing i'm
even hearing people on the political
left side
talk about the democrat party instead of
calling it the democratic party
which does some work okay um
i don't have a problem with an increased
awareness of
hey language has consequences and the
people who are affected
are asking for you to use different
language right it can be
annoying on a given day it can be
frustrating it takes a lot of energy
i don't have a problem i do have a
problem if we do end up getting
distracted
and i don't agree that the tussle over
language right now
has to be a distraction it definitely is
sometimes
but it doesn't have to be i'd rather us
talk about
the structures and if we're going to
orient the language make sure we orient
the language
towards the structures too but when i'm
asking for for someone
in my organization when i when i say hey
we give pronouns here
those are structural issues not just
language issues and i make sure that the
way we describe it is to say
this little thing that you can do with
your behaviors is tied to these larger
structural things
doesn't have to be either or and when we
make it as if it's either or
we create kind of divisions within
people who largely agree anyways
yes that's part of it for me too is like
if you're going to listen to me like
you're not the person i need to worry
about
i need to worry about the person who's
like you know nowhere near this podcast
um so so to re so to return to your
ascent
so you write this dissertation uh you
become
uh an academic and then you become
frustrated you're like hey i'm coming up
with all these great ideas look at my
great ideas like let's try them out in
real life
which is a very rare thing for an
academic to do um so how the heck did
you
operationalize you know like and what
were the ideas you were trying to bring
into the world
yeah so it happened on a dare i mean
literally there was a
black woman who impugned my manhood i
don't know i didn't ask if i can curse
on this podcast
[ __ ] yeah all right well so she she said
one of the first things out of her mouth
i think it's literally the first said i
don't think you have the balls to do
anything real with your life
what who the heck would say that's like
you could have said hello
first my name is but that's not how she
she rolls and so
we were instant sibling because i was
like oh thanks for dispelling my uh
stereotype that all cops are [ __ ]
um and she was like look the folks who
do
academic stuff they write in your fancy
journals um they make you know decent
living living they're not accountable to
anybody
you want to write about racism in the
criminal justice system [ __ ] deal
with racism in the criminal justice
system
and she invited me i put that in quotes
i'm out to denver to see if there was
anything useful i could possibly do
and after spending significant time out
there like and i wasn't sure for a while
i want to be really clear
um after spending significant time out
there i was like look
you guys get trainings all the time and
trainings are really weak levers for
change
if you want to change what's going on
change the incentive structure you have
for your officers
and once you've done that you'll have
some some information you can use to say
the way that policing is getting used in
the first place
is jacked up it was racist from the
start but as a
as a police department you're gonna have
a hard time doing that up front so first
change the incentive structure you give
to the officers
and they started doing that and it turns
out
fewer black folks get beat up fewer
folks in general get beat up fewer black
folks in particular fewer arrests and i
was like hey
fewer of these things would be good
maybe we can do this again
and that's how we started what were the
ins first what year was this and then
what were the incentives and what did
you try and shift them to
so the first year that she talked about
my absence of balls
was 2007 um and then we went to
to back to denver pretty much that that
year and i spent like a month and a half
living with her um and her husband um
like doing that commute and all the rest
and then by the time that we were done
beginning of 2008 we thought we had a
thing
that was going to be useful for more
than one department and it was
don't go where there's low-level
problems
go where there's big problems it's a
huge controversial thing in 2008
right but don't go to the places where
people are making complaints about
someone being suspicious
go to the places where someone is doing
great harm
and when you do that you'll reduce the
burden on black folks
you'll reduce the footprint of law
enforcement in these communities that
are already
overwrought and you'll increase the the
amount that you're intervening
on the things that those communities
actually care about which is the body
count
that was the big stuff so that that
sounds eminently reasonable
uh they took your recommendations which
is awesome and then they
found that the results were positive and
then you said we got to do this again
like we did it in denver we're gonna and
so at what point did you actually
co-found the center and how does one
co-found a center at a school
so it was in 2008 not by october end of
that year
that we're like we need some pamphlets
and to call this something
we were very bad at naming things so we
called it the consortium
for police leadership in equity you
should have called a republican
i've been like yeah what do i name this
thing
so yeah consortium as your lead word is
already a loser
um so we eventually uh renamed it the
center for police equity but the idea
was
hey police have a lot of power in these
situations and there's some who in good
faith are trying to do better
um how do we mainline to them the things
that
that communities have been trying to say
but they have been listening to and
that's how we got started
um in 2008 and the way you do it is you
say you call yourself a center
and you make sure that i was i just
moved to ucla i was like hey do you guys
mind and they're like no and so now
we're a center
we didn't have a c3 until a couple years
ago because we were just at the
university and we used the university as
a fiscal sponsor so fun you were just a
center so any academic listening to this
if you want to start a center
just gotta clear it by the dean who at
this point will probably say yes to
anything
[Music]
so uh so 2008 you start the center
um in ucla and then what like did police
departments come knocking down your door
i'm not sure if they did maybe they did
so this is the thing this is everybody's
assuming that we had to go like johnny
appleseed hat in hand and be like please
uh let us make you less racist it was
totally
like i'm from philly um and i had my
my hypothesis walking into this as a
scientist where the bigots are gonna
bigot
policing attracts a lot of bigots and
their bigotry is what i see in the
streets what i felt
in my in growing up um as a as a black
guy um
from philly in the suburbs and it turns
out that while that may also be true
cops showed up in there were 15 on 2008
who were like yo how do we be down
they're like like we really we genuinely
want to make this better and you're not
going to call us names
at the beginning at the very least and
we're happy to make significant
structural change institutionally like
inside of our
incredible apartment and we're shocking
to me i was like i didn't offer them
cookies we like we bought a couple of
them a chicken lunch
and that was it because and i was gonna
say every single one the very intake
we're going to find racism systemic
racism for which you are responsible
so when you sign up for this we're going
to find
racism and they're like okay that's
scary or i don't
agree with you you're not gonna find any
racism here whatever it was
we told them up front and when we gave
it back to them they did some of the
things that we told them to do
and what were those things typically in
addition to go where the problems are
most serious
and avoid the areas where it's people
like crying wolf that sounds like
yeah and so so that was a lot of that um
it was also hey these are problems you
shouldn't be dealing with and
the thing that i think is is ironic
about the moment we're in right now
where you have a lot of organizers and
activists calling for
shrinking the footprint of law
enforcement or for full-on abolition
is that a lot of their demands were were
i was hearing in my ears in 2008 from
police chiefs
we shouldn't be in mental health we
shouldn't be in child welfare we
shouldn't be
in homelessness we shouldn't be in
substance abuse
and we would say you're right get out of
it
give some of your budget over this was
way back before abolition was
was popular in the way that it is now
give some of your budget over
to doing some other stuff ask the city
for these sets of resources so you have
partnerships that are
not you you should be doing less deal
with violence
and nothing else so those sorts of
things and then
interventions that would remind them
that most of their contact was not with
people who were
trying to shoot them but just like a
training here
a policy there that would do that those
were the first big things that came out
and the next the next round was a way
for them to give themselves and for the
community to get
feedback loops on it so literally let's
measure
how out of whack you are in terms of
your behaviors
to what your values say you should be
and now you've got a feedback loop not
just for measuring crime which is what
they all
did but for measuring something like
equity
in your behaviors and that was also a
driver of better behavior so like
arrests go down use of force goes down
officer injuries go down when you start
measuring that stuff and keeping track
of it
that's one reason i love you so much
phillip and your work is that you change
the measurements
uh if all you're doing is measuring uh
crime
and people uh in prison cells and the
rest of it
then you're missing 90 of the picture
which is like what are these other
interactions
you know what what else is happening on
happening on a daily basis that's good
or bad
uh so you bring in different
measurements uh
to different communities and we're
talking about way back in like 2008 2009
so how the heck did you get the resource
to do this like if these police
departments are showing up and you're
just a grad student hanging out in la
like how the heck do you
somehow multiply uh the impact in all
these cities that aren't denver
yeah so by that time i was a so by the
time i was going to denver i was in a
faculty job
and by the time i got to ucla i was like
a known faculty person among social
psychologists and known by like 12
people
um but the deal was police departments
wanted to pay us
and that seemed like a bad idea to me
because
if i'm getting money from the police
department how could a community that
doesn't trust the police
trust what i had to say so we refused
money from the place where we could get
money from
the other place was that we got we heard
from community activists were like yo we
need this
um and so we'll we'll take up a
collection i was like how am i gonna tax
black people in these vulnerable
communities more than they're already
getting taxed so
no thank you so we couldn't take money
from the communities that were under
duress
and i didn't feel like we could take
money from law enforcement so i wrote a
lot of grant applications
like we got money from the national
science foundation um we got money from
uh ford foundation we got money from
macarthur foundation from kellogg
from william t grant i got money as a
scholar to do that i just i was
couch cushions and hat in hand from
places
where they wouldn't put a thumb on the
scale of the work that we were doing in
the community
what a champ you are man i want to hit
fast forward just for fun like what the
heck is the
center's budget today because i feel
like people must be throwing money at
you now i don't know if that's right
[Laughter]
so i think it's really important to get
the context of the last year
so in 2017 there's 220 million dollars
of philanthropic money
going to criminal justice stuff broadly
220 and that's more than had ever been
in the nation's history 220 million
by the 115 billion going to policing
alone
in terms of municipal and state budgets
but 220 million
200 million of that is for decarceration
efforts 10 million re-entry and 10
million dollars to policing
that means we were funding the issue of
policing to the issue of incarceration
as a twenty to one issue
you show me any community in the world
where the pain of policing to the pain
of incarceration is a twenty to one
issue
but that's how we were funding it so our
budget is
tiny compared to the money that we give
out to the money that is is in the
budgets to do
de-incarceration efforts that's bail
pre-trial progressive prosecutors
um restorative justice work um deferment
projects
tiny tiny tiny it's still about 2.5 was
going to policing before last year
last year about a third of the money
towards um uh
uh criminal justice was going towards
policing and it was mostly going to
organizations that were 15 people in one
city
20 people over there a network of
organizations um trying to figure out
what they were doing
all over the place so now we think that
the budget around policing
is in the 200 to 300 million dollar
range nationally right
so that's what we're talking about still
tiny compared to the problem
yes but that's as of just last year yeah
obviously because of uh the national
moment um
and george floyd's murder um so
you are one of the um behemoths in that
space
i mean not
you know in terms of the because you've
been doing the work since 2008 and
um and had these impacts so you had this
you had this grant writing spree
in 2010 you're doing this on top of your
faculty job
uh now i discovered you and this says
something about me but whatever
um uh with your ted talk in uh
2019 so what was that experience like in
was that all of a sudden like wow like
you know all these
all these people reaching out to you
that that had an earlier
yeah so 2019 um we are 19
people um at cpe and that makes us the
largest organization on race and public
safety in the world
at 19 people um the ted process
was a as a funding process right so it
was a
kind of grant process but you can't
really like you could apply but it's
it's a
winnowing process and at the end of that
process
um we had the funding to become
like a 75-person organization huge
explosion
right nice job tim you did it this time
so that was great for us um and for the
other organizations that were able to go
through things like that like the the
uh the bail project um robert
steinberg's group um that came with the
year before us
um after last year we're gonna be well
north of 100 150 uh people
um and the hope is that we're at that
size to do the work at scale
to do things like not just we were doing
before on data analysis and giving it
back
but like what we did in ithaca where we
helped
the community again these are all
community-led efforts we help the
community figure out how to come up with
a
process where they didn't want a police
department anymore
they wanted a department of public
safety and community solutions
that was majority unarmed civilian-led
and was not going to send armed
respondents
to a non-violent process if you don't
have
if there's not a gun in the area you're
not sending somebody with a gun
that's the way that the folks in ithaca
and tompkins county wanted to set up
their public safety
but how do you deal with the budget
stuff how do you deal with the city
charter how do you deal with the local
politics how do you deal with all the
national folks who want to get in on it
that's where i feel like cpe has really
built up its muscles
to figure that out to guide a process
through
so that the city council can pass it
unanimously and we can start
implementation which is where we're at
in ithaca and tompkins county new york
right now so anyone who
who this sounds good to feel free to
move to ithaca new york it's beautiful
[Laughter]
sounds like it's going to have like a
very different approach to public safety
than a lot of the country
[Music]
thank this man thank phillip uh but for
for that important though i'm sure there
are
awesome leaders in ithaca trying to make
it happen um
and it sounds like the grantors have
come your direction
and now you're taking it to the next
level where you're trying to tell
stories
in this space and this is something that
that depresses me philip i'm going to be
honest with you
um but it feels like everything is
degenerating into content
[Laughter]
i mean like art content politics content
thought content uh and and the clearest
emblem
of this to me is that barack and
michelle obama the most successful
people in the country may be
you know like uh ex-president x-first
lady like what are they
they're netflix producers
like they're like the highest thing we
can aspire to
and you know it's something that i
grappled with myself
uh you know running for president a lot
of
what was necessary was to try to produce
content
whatever the heck that meant in a given
moment um
and but but this is the way change
will occur we believe because it's the
only way to reach people
um so now you're the president of the
relatively newly formed
justice rx uh and people listening to
this all like is there anything this guy
doesn't do
uh but how did how did this what is
justice rx and how did it come about
yeah and so just to go backwards it is
the people in ithaca
it's the the leaders i know i know i'm
just kidding
like no but this is actually important
because it's about the stories we tell
about how change happens
right so it's those folks who get their
stories stolen from them because they're
by you fill up by you national person
right exactly
who's a national person who comes along
like i want to say we helped the
community were the folks who did it
in every place nerds unaccountable
um academics was i'm only accountable to
uh
you know like a couple of small rules in
yales now because because now i got
tenure right so what what the heck can
you say to me
um we can't really be in the lead
and it's really important to say so that
means the folks who are living it have
to be in the lead and that's why
places like justice rx and um like
patrice cullers who also has a deal
at warner bros developing mostly
children's programming
that's why that stuff is important the
most
powerful art form is storytelling
and the reason i know that is because of
my colleagues who are neuroscientists
because storytelling rewires the brain
memory is the stories that we tell about
the world that we've seen and can
imagine
and memory is what we latch onto
for reality the fabric of reality is
storytelling i'm not just trying to like
like really blow the minds of the folks
who are high listening to this right now
like that's real talk but when was the
last time we held storytellers
accountable for the powers that they
wield
and so what the reason the real reason
that i got in this was um
every time you see another black person
who shot and killed
inside of 15 minutes were having an
argument about whether or not they
deserved it
and the language is well was it a
justified shooting and if we say it's
justified be like well that's tragic
but i guess there's nothing we can do it
was justified the shooting was justified
that means they deserve to die that's
what it translates into
and that's a storytelling problem it's a
problem of the structures that we erect
to tell the stories to make meaning of
the things that we see every day
and you can't undo that with great
social science
or with sort of institutional change you
can't even get at that
at a structural level outside of the way
we tell stories about how the world is
set up
so i actually think it's good that
everything is content
i think it's bad because i still can't
figure out what i want to watch on
netflix and
there's not another sci-fi thing that i
can plug into and get
enjoyment out of but that there's this
explosion of content is a good thing
because we can start holding content
creators accountable for the power
that they wield well that was the best
case for
what the obamas are doing
i've heard uh and the tomorrow war
on amazon prime uh if you haven't seen
it is a fine sci-fi watch
free uh anyway just letting you know you
just like switch from netflix to amazon
prime tomorrow or chris pratt
you can thank me later uh
but but your characterization of what
happens when
a black man is shot and killed by the
police is
completely accurate uh you know people
like study the grainy video or whatnot
and like you know try and draw their
conclusion
and and i took it as like a way that to
your point it's like you're trying to
make sense of the world
and there are a lot of people who want
to believe it's justified because it's
a better story to your point than that
an innocent black man was shot uh
because of a bad cop
to me the proximate cause is the gun
it's like you said if like that there is
no gun then you know
the shooting doesn't happen um so like
it or not like those are the terms i
tend to think in i try and think about
like the actual
like physical variable um
but to your point like that there are
very powerful narratives that
underpin things that we see and accept
uh and and see as like somehow
unavoidable or inevitable or
natural in some demented way
[Music]
so you've learned so much you've done so
much work in this space
let's say that i was a police chief in a
city
um and was trying to make things better
the the things that i've gotten
already from this conversation and past
conversations with you are look you need
to measure different things aside from
just
crime and criminals you need to try to
orient your resources towards the real
problems that affect people
and and not um the fake problems
uh you need to accept that there's a
degree of racism baked into your
department
and that you know in my mind too and
this is something that might be
controversial to people
like i see racism and tribalism as
something of a spectrum
where you know like you're not going to
be able to expunge it entirely
uh in an institution but you want to
keep it from killing people
you want to keep it from doing the thing
that you know it's all like
if someone runs into me on the street
and like the first thing they think
about me is like oh
asian guy and then they draw a couple of
conclusions based on that
like i'm okay with that in part because
i'll never even know what happens
like as long as they keep those those
conclusions
from um making them you know like you
know scream
something you know like xenophobic and
hostile i mean
like it's the stop short of some kind of
harm or negative action but you know
like that like there's a degree of
um of race that you know just ambient
um so having police departments accept
that in in their departments and try and
find the areas they can actually correct
for it
having reminders that the vast majority
of interactions they have are
perfectly benign and not you know that
their lives aren't on the line
um what are the other things that you've
done in different departments that have
uh driven results
yeah and so there's there's a lot in
there let me see if i can thread some of
that
back into the reply so the first thing
is
i wanna i i want chiefs but also
when we help to train uh activists um uh
when we engage with local non-profits
you wanna make sure that if you're
talking about racism you specify what
level it's operating at
so you're situational that's just the
immediate thing all right so
i wanna make sure that if my officer has
negative stereotypes about a group
that they're not acting on them i want
to i want to interrupt that i want to
make the situation safer
which means sometimes i remove the
officer from it i have a mental health
responder
right ideally not through the police
department um but i just want to make
that situation safer
the second piece is we can change some
policies so that you're not showing up
to those things in the first place
that's an institutional level of racism
because if
the institution has decided we're going
to do um drug possession busts
in open air drug markets guess what
you're going to be rounding up a lot of
black
and brown folks you are not going to be
touching a lot of white folks
and that's actually not getting at
public health it's not getting a public
safety you're just
targeting the vulnerable people so
that's an institutional level of racism
but then there's structural stuff the
things that happen outside of policing
like why on earth did those things
become crimes in the first place
why on earth are we sending law
enforcement to a mental health call on
the first one like we didn't used to do
that all the time
we had folks who could come out and do
that we had social workers we had
institutionalized medicine
it was terrible too and awful and racist
and sexist and gross
but it wasn't always police what
happened was we defunded those public
goods in vulnerable communities
interesting word there and we replace
them with law enforcement
so what i tell law enforcement is you
guys are often getting beat up
for the things that you do in the
situation which you should fix the
things that are happening in your
department which you should fix
and the things that happen before it
ever gets to your department which
you're not directly in control of
and you should speak out about that
because if you are
the replacement for mental health and
homelessness and substance abuse
you're going to get beat up for it and
at some level i mean like
who else they gonna beat up they should
beat up the politicians they should be
up the people who voted that in
they should beat up the sort of
narrative the stories that we tell about
who we are
uh as americans that everybody gets to
make up their own life like we're not
all dependent on
a huge wide ecosystem that we grew up in
and that we participate in
but also it's going to be you so if
you're asking me what i tell police
chiefs i say
learn about the structural racism that
you're being used to further
not just the institutional and
interpersonal racism that you feel like
you're in direct control over
because right now we're at a point where
the country wants the structural stuff
to stop and and if you're not part of
that solution
and you're actively part of the problem
then you shouldn't be surprised when
folks are pissed off at you
i've got it it's refund the services
instead of defunding the ways like
refund of the services
you were only about three years uh after
the oakland anti-police
terrorism project because that's what
they've been saying um
actually for some time and you're
starting to hear some folks who said who
said defund
talking about refunding communities for
real
i love it i mean uh we've under-invested
in so many ways in neighborhoods
families
communities particularly obviously black
and brown communities
you know i've seen it over and over
again anyone with any common sense
who's been in america has seen it
uh and and we're spending billions and
billions of dollars on uh
quasi-militarized or
i mean not even quasi just militarized
police force
um uh and so the the expenditures aren't
the right direction
uh you know and when i've spoken to you
about it uh you know like going to
police departments and trying to help
them solve their problems
you know it's solutions oriented it's
like look like
and the fact that you've been building
this common ground with police
departments and communities who are
trying to do the right thing over the
last number of years it's really worth
its weight in gold
i'm so glad that you've gotten the
recognition for the work that you're
doing
you know you do it for the right reasons
i mean you're like doing it to do it um
but the fact that the world's come your
way in part because of various tragedies
uh
you know just very grateful to you man
you're like a an inspiration to me and a
lot of other people
uh and a hero to me and should be to a
lot of other people
if someone uh so i'm going to try and
spill the beans on something maybe i'm
going to make news here on yang speaks
uh like do you know what justice rx like
what your first projects are going to be
like you know where where we might see
them
um we are not in a position to be
talking about what those would be just
yet um
i keep uh community secrets most and
uh the hollywood industry secrets second
most um so no i can't talk about but i
can talk about the kinds of things
um that we're gonna want to be showing
and i use the example of
of let's use the the the horrible
tragedy of micaiah bryant
um who was killed um in the same general
vicinity
um of the trial of derek chauvin
and so it's a young black woman um she
had a knife it appeared she was lunging
at somebody else and people like well
that's a justified shooting she was
going to kill somebody you don't want
the police to intervene there and here's
the deal
we know the story of mikaya bryant in
the 15
10 seconds of body cam footage that we
saw
but if you're a black woman black girl
who's been in the foster care system
who's complained about
abuse through that system the
the rank rate of physical abuse of
sexual abuse particularly of young girls
through those systems is so violent
that when that story ends in tragedy
even if you don't want to fault the
officer we should be telling the stories
of the lives
that led up to that point right guilty
people
shouldn't get shot and killed by the
state either
and so those are the kinds of stories
that we're going to want to be telling
stories that literally untell the lies
that we tell about who we are
and we tell so many lies about who we
are in this country
that my hope is there's going to be a
lot of stories to untell
that we're going to be able to to bring
out to the world
the idea that what happened was there
was slavery
and then white people decided slavery is
wrong
we're gonna fight a war to free the
slaves and the slaves were sitting
around being like oh that sounds like a
good idea
thank you that's a lie that got untold
the first time in 1935 by dubois w.b
dubois who says
actually black people were instrumental
in freeing the slaves
in fact black people freed themselves as
a part of the process of the civil war
we don't tell that story
even when we tell the stories of the
civil war in primary education we don't
talk about the fact that the
the the northern armies were coming down
with the thought
yeah slavery's okay right like slavery
like
we're fighting because because the
insistence on slavery is the problem but
slavery's i don't actually care about
slaves
and it was the fact that union armies
were gonna get their asses handed to
them unless black folks decided yeah
we're gonna get involved in this black
people freed ourselves and if we told
that story the right way
the idea that abolitionists are
advancing right now that we do this to
we
free us it's historically
necessary it's historical momentum it's
not a radical new idea
those are the kinds of things that we're
going to be telling with justice rx
wow you've ginned up a lot of
anticipation
i'm sure because that sounds epic and
amazing
um you what you just talked about the
civil war reminded me of that movie
glory with denzel and the rest of it uh
you know
uh you know i mean like it was the 80s
so i'm sure it was messed up in various
ways but
you know but certainly love that movie
as a kid um so if someone wants to help
you in your work
uh philip aside from following you and
social media following your work
um perhaps supporting uh the center for
policing equity
uh directly but yeah what can they do
most important thing you can do to
support all of the work that i'm doing
is get involved locally it's not give me
money it's not i mean if you want to
follow my twitter account then
uh you know condolences to you it's a
lot of pictures of of wildlife these
days
because the rest of this space is so
incredibly toxic and awful
get involved locally think about
situational institutional and structural
problems
all three levels all interacting um and
stay involved because what happened
after this summer is everybody said oh
we had a racial reckoning we didn't have
a reckoning
like we had a racial we had a racial
sort of uh
like blip of of awakeness for about 15
minutes
and people didn't strap in to realize
this is these are problems we've been
engaged in for 400 years so we're not
going to get them out in 400 days
right it's going to take a lot longer to
get ourselves out of it so do whatever
you need to do to have your whole life
and be involved locally in public safety
and criminal legal issues get educated
read new people read old people and
be an adult whose life is engaged in
this work
because the places where we go when
there is a critical
mass of really brilliant folks already
there
we can be useful oh yeah places where
that's not the case
we we're useless we're just a bunch of
outsiders trying to help folks
get themselves organized and without the
infrastructure we we can't do anything
useful
so the best thing you can do for me is
do for your local community
which means listen to the people who are
already there get involved in stuff
that's already going on get coached
coach yourself up and then strap in for
the long haul
maybe people can do what they've done in
ithaca where they end up getting so much
community support around a different
vision of public safety
and then philip can show up
here to help thank you phillip
congratulations on everything
uh man i i've learned a ton i'm sure
everyone listening to this uh and just
so strong uh so positive
so human uh uh you're helping
move the entire uh world forward man
just really grateful to you
i appreciate it um if i had one thing to
say to everybody
at the tail end which i i hear people do
on this podcast i'd say this
the thing that i i pray on every day
right before i start my day and right
after i've ended it
is i pray to try and make it easier for
people to do the right thing maybe just
a little bit easier
and right now especially as there's such
fever pitch on
disagreement on tactics right
disagreement on well we're going to do
it this way i know anybody who thinks
that anybody's been involved in that is
it
it makes it harder for folks to do the
right thing and if that's our ultimate
goal sometimes that's critique sometimes
that's encouragement
if that's our ultimate goal the day has
been made better by the work that we did
do the right thing i think i've heard
that somewhere too thank you phillip
[Music]
you